i'll just wait every night on halloween
i'll go have sex they call her the night
rider
[Music]
everyone has to do a language go to a
quarter french
okay uh
we can do all asian languages
you got one uh
no okay
yo soy americano
hi how do you vietnamese uh
all right hello everybody
there you go
speaking of blending cultures it's
thanksgiving this thanksgiving speaking
of pillaging and raping it's oh jesus no
one was talking about the white one's
saying that too so you guys she is proud
of
welcome back to another episode of big
move yeah it's a thanksgiving episode
where we're going to catch you up on all
the stuff that's going on uh you have me
hi it's gina if you guys are listening
yep it's jess yep it's nikki
it's us yeah you guys purposely try to
piss me yeah
it's the first episode of the day so we
still have a lot of energy we all have
all the coffee in us all the coffee we
want to catch you up on our lives you
know things things change very changing
quickly we're not actually friends in
real life so this is the time we get
together
we get to figure out whatever
you're not friends if you don't see each
other physically yeah
it hurts our feelings
you're not my friend if you don't see me
physically i don't see any of my friends
physically since the person that moved
to another state she's actually still
holding exactly she's like
why aren't you guys visiting
you'll never visit me anymore she just
keeps moving further and further marina
del rey might as well have been in
another state
well now i found out that i could
possibly go to france oh my god the
opportunity i look like [ __ ] i look
like all the locations where my company
is at and i'm like oh there's one in
paris this place already bought a beret
yeah she's like calling us
at like two in the morning because it's
done her time and she's like you're not
my friend why is never answering
no one texting back it's later in my
time [ __ ] it's early or your time oh
it's true you should be there earlier
you're in the next day
there you go whatever you're so lazy
that's the point what in the future
yeah you can't you can't be saying you
don't have friends if you're the one
being a bad friend what how am i you're
a bad bad
three days to get to you yes it does and
if you love me you'll do it so our house
is officially sold
i'm renting right now this is this is my
rental a rent bag welcome to my rental
in l.a so this block of episodes is the
last time we're going to be in this set
so yeah oh yeah we're going to be in a
different set after this block gets used
up i'm just going to knock on the door
next month just like whoever you never
knocked when i lived here that's true
i let myself in i live here now like now
she comes over
yeah we're still going to be in this set
until like for uploading until like feb
early february oh [ __ ]
i live here
yeah
dude this is crazy like you sold it fast
i know that's how cool this place it was
a really fast sell a fast close so this
is how realistic we got a bunch of
offers within the first two days
then we picked uh and accepted an offer
within the first two days and then we
closed within 22 days wow yeah i have no
idea how to buy a house that's amazing
well tune in to [ __ ] they don't tell you
because we won't do a full episode
of selling and buying houses i plug our
show big mood on [ __ ] they don't tell
you and steve always gets mad because he
calls us the chief competitor i should
have been
like i should have just made it super
creepy and bought the house and
redecorated exactly the same way yeah
have a podcast and be like welcome to
this
alone
this one's decorated with stars and
crystals
a little bit of cat people like real
life
yeah i'm just creepily filming my own
podcast by myself yeah perfectly
versions of us
just tell me about your life jess i'm
doing your voice
i was thinking about the chicken the
chicken is like
i do all your voices but it's like
extremely racial yeah
i'm like it's yeehaw with her and then
you're super mexican
has a hard time letting go you guys just
let her have it
dude if you lose your mind and go down
that road i would love to see it
i'd watch yes
from our respective people i paid for
that show so so you guys are moving into
your new house soon in vegas the house
that you fell in love with you excited
for this i'm so [ __ ] excited but it's
bittersweet because i really we loved
living here how long were you here we're
here almost four years like three and a
half years and um it was our first
piece of property that we ever bought so
there's a lot of like it's my first time
owning a house so you can like decorate
it however you want to you can change
the walls you can give a lot of freedom
and light fixtures change everything and
so i felt like i like learned a lot with
this house and um there's a lot of
memories and i mean we spent the whole
pandemic locked up in this house
it's really real me too the layout's
really weird so
um steve is in like this whole different
area that's like you can't even hear him
in his office it's like a whole
different wing of the house and then um
i'm upstairs but so
there's that but then also i just feel
like
i'm i'm ready to look at some somewhere
new like i'm ready to explore and there
seems like there's a lot of
opportunities in vegas i want to get
into
like decorating a like a single family
home like actually doing like remodels
that require tools and i have a
contractor friend out there who invests
in real estate and he's going to help me
like learn that whole market and so
there's a lot to like explore like i'm
going to follow him basically on all of
his remodels because he like flips
houses and stuff
yeah and so those are just like things
that i'm passionate about at this point
in my life and when i moved to la like i
had different passions and
this place worked for when i when it was
those passions and now i'm like well
i've just been heading this direction
and it feels more natural to like follow
this path and
um also poker there's lots of poker
there and
oh yeah poker
live your dj dreams yeah oh and the
house is twice as big as this house but
like almost the same price that we sold
our condo for and it's on a lake
actually it's in between two lakes how
far are you from the script um i think
15 to 20 minutes oh nice yeah
yeah so uh yeah but there's no traffic
in las vegas so
everyone's like 10 minutes away and the
la or i have a lot of friends that live
in las vegas too and
it's so funny when they're like oh we
have to go like um
dinner's in five minutes i'm like what
we're not gonna make it how far is this
place is
everything's like five minutes away wow
oh you mean there's no traffic like in
the town yeah vegas because it's like
you look on the map and it's like oh
it's five miles away like we're never
gonna make it like here if you want to
go five miles it's gonna take you 30
minutes yeah yeah but
but there it's like it's legit like five
miles is five minutes that's amazing
nice you're there is there anything that
you're like afraid of anything that's
making you kind of nervous
um ghosts i'm like uh excuse me you know
what
i know that this house isn't haunted and
it was very important to me not yet and
you know what i don't know i've only
been to this new house one time when i
made the offer
because you know in l.a
well the other thing is i've never lived
outside of california so in california
like you're when you move like you're
seeing the place you're going to move to
pretty often like you've seen it like a
lot like you haven't just seen it one
time and this place i've literally only
been in that one time and there's people
that move across like oh yeah there's
people like move across the country
unseen they don't even know i got my
apartment without seeing it that's crazy
but i knew the neighborhood so i was
like it's probably yeah plus there's
just a rental like this yeah i can get
out of it in a few months we're putting
equity in this [ __ ] well i guess like
the most important question about the
whole moving thing is which room is my
room
right so this this house has five
bedrooms
you will have
um you have so much [ __ ] just you
wouldn't need the guest bedroom has a
view of the lake
yeah
why are there two living rooms does the
master have been fallen uh no no it has
like a bunch of trees i would just move
into the guest room or like there's no
foliage in las vegas like where are you
gonna get your nature like [ __ ] this
neighborhood that i'm moving to looks
just like california like i see no yeah
but like a nice neighborhood in
california like not my california
neighborhood not my actual like trees
and bells like palm trees and stuff oh i
can't wait to visit it too and it has a
beach too what yeah yeah it does so
one [ __ ] place in vegas with a beach
like an artist everyone's gonna know
where you live well i think they're
gonna know because there's not a lot of
lakes
but oh yeah so now we have a place to
stay at whenever we go to vegas we'd
have to book hotels hell yeah
and it's really only 15 minutes it's so
fast
i'm gonna build a hotel though that's
true that's true you can [ __ ] in our
house
just make sure you stay in your wings
i don't want you guys hearing us have
sex i want to hear
i've heard you guys chris i don't want
it the other way
you almost knocked down that big bear
captain i never
well your husband almost knocked it down
in my in my list of to-do's and
friendships with you guys uh hearing
steve orgasm was not one of the to-do
things i wanted
the room next to us you had it coming
that's true
you knew what you signed up for
so yeah now it's only fair and you got
to hear me it's fine i'll fake it i hear
you come here
gross thank you
so one day you guys have to be out of
here by the end of the end of the month
yeah
we're moving well yeah they they gave us
30 days here so are you getting rid of
most stuff yeah i have a couch there'll
be a um we're keeping the couch oh yeah
give me the couch on the bed [ __ ] you
already have like couches that you don't
even use at your house oh you can have
the couch in steve's room
yeah yeah
it's a pull-out couch okay
this one has a lot of cat pee on it you
don't want it it's okay so does the
other one though that's true yeah
everything has cat pee on it so what
percentage like are you gonna keep like
90 of the stuff oh no i'm we're keeping
the couch and the bed
and
steve's desk and my vanity and i think
that's like that's like it
that's a lot of stuff wow that's going
to be left behind yeah like that oh wait
we're taking that
i'm like but everything yeah everything
else is like
just how are you going to transport your
big ass see that's the thing is that i
need room for plants yeah so i have like
quite a few big plants that i that's
like so huge i feel like that's bigger
than it got bigger that's bigger than
the movie moving pants
when we moved it fit but like i think it
grew another foot after because this
ceiling is way taller than our apartment
ceiling was you're gonna have to like
lay them diagonally or something yeah
maybe
just flapping in the wind in the truck
she's dying
it's just like branches
this is all cute
i could stay in one place for 20 years i
would but um it's just time i knew this
wasn't a forever home
stop talking about my plants flapping
some bears
embarrassing picture you had that really
big fig fiddler yes that only thing
upstairs and i was like
you just [ __ ] pull
[Laughter]
i got a video to show you later there's
a sunflower in the tornado that's
holding on for dear life and they edited
a face on it and they're playing like
death metal music
that's the greatest i got to send you
the video later
she shows up there's no more leaves it's
just a branch
she's crying
us three we've never left california
right so i have oh you have living i was
fifteen like that only one year and max
but you can't really switch like your
driver's license your registration like
oh that's a [ __ ] dude yeah i've never
done it
in texas it was a [ __ ] was that hard
when you moved to america tiff
oh my god
when i was born
it was easy
do you want it
since you wanna know she moves around
because you can't say well
yeah i've never had to do that yeah so i
wouldn't know what that's like like
casey's moved from texas to florida to
california
yeah same with steve he's moved from
uh colts indiana to virginia you only
know where he lived based on this yeah
from cults to
new patriots
uh he sticks with his team but we were
both we both decided cause he's a colts
fan i'm a packers fan and we've both
been die hard but when we move to vegas
we're just gonna drop our teams and be
die hard raiders
[Laughter]
oh i always remembered it because
nostradamus and that's how it is okay
yeah i've never moved to california i
realized i was born and raised here and
just never left yeah place to leave
that's most of california is pretty easy
you're not from here one of us
yeah people that i don't know a lot of
people that have left california that if
you were born here
like i like very few it's the same in
texas still not a lot of people really
leave yeah i feel like everyone i mean a
lot of people just don't really leave
their house it's pretty common i would
love to live in a different country
again let me tell you when i'm older
dude if i can get a japanese visa or a
passport now i'm abandoning everything
here
i'm out can i come
back that's why i'm moving to vegas
because you can go to paris you can go
to new york you can go to
china
wherever you want to go you can be you
can go around the world
to paris yesterday yeah
dude that's actually a reason why i was
like
hardcore really considering florida for
a second because i'm like epcot i'm
gonna be near my cousin
and then on that side of the country
it's so much closer to the other side of
the world
yeah
they got drinks from france
you'll get to skip out on that like five
hour flight from the west six hours from
l.a to the yeah from west coast to east
coast it takes six hours so much extra
time yeah so then i like wipe that out
and then just get to go to europe or
anywhere on that side florida yeah we
really are gonna be the podcast of the
traveling pants or
sisterhood of the traveling podcasts
traveling podcast pants yeah
it's like
the word pants
the pants of the traveling sisterhood
welcome to podcasts
guests
pants we should change traveling podcast
pants moves yeah there you go we can
change our podcast name just saying
it's a big handsome booth we could just
change we can just change our branding
every year the traveling mood let's
first talk about doordash so shout outs
to our sponsor doordash doordash
connects you with the restaurants you
love right now to right to your door and
now you can get the grocery essentials
that you need with doordash too you can
get drinks snacks and other household
items delivered in under an hour which
i'm really looking forward to once this
baby comes through because then i could
just picture it we're just so
like discombobulated from not sleeping
like being sleep-deprived so we forget
we forget to buy diapers and it's like
wait doordash can hook us up with some
diapers right now so ordering is super
easy you just open the doordash app you
choose what you want from where you want
and your items will be left safely
outside your door with the contactless
delivery drop-off setting with over 300
000 partners in the u.s puerto rico
canada and australia you can support
your neighborhood go-to's or choose from
your favorite national restaurants like
popeye's chipotle and cheesecake factory
cheesecake factory so for a limited time
our listeners can get 25 off and zero
delivery fees on their first order of 15
or more when you download the doordash
app and enter code
mood that's 25
off up to a 10 value and zero delivery
fees on your first order when you
download the doordash app in the app
store and enter code
mood don't forget that's code mood for
25 off your first order with doordash
subject to change terms apply
speech
we were all gathered here today to talk
about third love yeah yeah yeah
you are getting married into one exactly
like spice girl said when to become one
um
uh with third love comfort is always a
given the holidays can be hectic
stressful or downright uncomfortable
this holiday season give the gift of
comfort with third love tiffy's boobies
are changing because of pregnancy yes i
have had upgraded
bras for sure and third love is your one
stop shop for all the women in your life
ultra soft loungewear for mom fun
sleepover sets for your sister premium
activewear for your friends and lucks
intimate sets for that special someone
gifting third love means giving joy and
feeling good and all day wear that hug
better hold stronger and support longer
as a uh owner of a pair of breasts
actually i like my third love bro it's
so comfy i didn't like wearing bras for
the longest time because i'm wearing one
right now yeah i don't like wearing bras
either yeah i gave them up like five
years ago i hit 30 and i was like i'm
free good luck freedom but there are
sometimes you have to wear a bra and
third love has been super comfy you
might as well wear one that you can't
feel exactly it doesn't pinch it doesn't
leave weird marks on your body or weird
gaps even the underwiring like i don't
feel it you know like a lot of bras you
feel the underwire and it's like digging
into you like i don't feel it at all uh
third love is obsessed over each stitch
so you never have to think about how
something feels looks or wears while
trends come and go third love is always
stay true to one notion we do comfort
and you do you
third love brings comfort from the
sheets to the streets with the softest
sleepwear lux washable silk and bras
that you won't need to take off when you
get home love your fit guaranteed if not
exchanges and returns are free for 60
days and third love's team of expert fit
stylists are available via chat or text
to answer all your questions third love
is the largest donor of undergarments in
the us partnering with organizations
across the united states third love has
donated over 40 million dollars worth of
bras to help people in need
because people do need bras you know
people don't think about the little
things in life that people need feeling
is believing upgrade to everyday pieces
that love your body as much as we do
right now you can get 20 off your first
order go to third love dot com big mood
that's third love dot com slash big mood
for 20 off all right jess how about you
what's uh what's what's going on in
texas land in the house and just world
[ __ ] well you guys know how i was going
like a year without having sex yeah yeah
what are you doing
making fun of that for a while maybe for
a year
so i went 14.5 months and yes i'm going
to use math language 14 and a half 14.5
months
and then uh
spell ended smell ended
um
i don't know how much i want to share
about my dating life yet because i'm
actively dating
i honestly i haven't told anyone that
i've been on dates with that i even have
this show i'm just like putting myself
i'm just an accountant yes like i'm just
a [ __ ] boring girl an accountant no
you can't have my instagram which is all
the weeks that she didn't have sex which
is so funny because the tick tock um
joke is an accountant yeah exactly where
this is called an account because
there's a song where it's like oh what
do you do i'm an accountant yeah i
posted that one
yeah i posted that on my phone i've only
seen it from actual accountants that did
it
yeah it takes all that many accounts i
guess
30 year old humor so yeah i was like oh
accountants got their own jam that's
cool but for all you little gen z's or
is she she is an actual accountant
a counselor she's an actual cpa exam
i'll have my life she'll see peoria yes
she wants to see your pee pee and put it
in her a something like that
there's there's something there there's
something it's a workshop okay
so anyways
i'm not telling the guys i'm dating
about um my social media life because
i'm honestly trying to like ramp it down
like i deleted my twitter deleted my
facebook my instagram's private um so if
you're trying to follow me sorry you
probably won't get can't follow her
sorry
i'm gonna follow music on your instagram
um
it's like 90 something it drops i've
been losing a bunch i got up to like 110
and then it's been dropping steadily
ever since because i'm also not allowing
you people to come in and i think a lot
of it was bots and they're kind of like
slowly getting shut it off so
um but yeah so anyway um i haven't told
anyone about it and then but none of the
dates have gone through so like all the
guys have been on like i've met a lot of
really nice guys actually
like guys that are decent good job great
on paper seem good
some part of me worries a little bit too
because i'm like not this one not this
one there's so many they're like good
decent guys but i'm like not this one
i'm waiting for one that feels like it's
for me yeah but then i'm like what if
i'm just like so picky and then i get to
the bottom of the barrel and there's
nothing left
i think that way
i think abundance because i keep saying
no no no no no but they're all like
perfectly good guys let me ask you this
perfectly decent are you surprised that
you even found like decent guys because
i feel like before you started this you
weren't even sure if there were any
decent guys well i don't know them
enough to know if they're fully decent
but on paper but you know they've got
the right no i mean i knew that there's
like guys in
you know my field or a similar feel like
tech or something that are you know they
have decent jobs and they have they look
good on paper i know that those guys
exist there's a reason why you're saying
no as well well yeah it's just because
there's no chemistry i guess so like
there's maybe compatibility here there
but i'm like waiting for i need a spark
too see we've talked about this on the
show because i remember you saying you
wanted a boring guy but i was like well
no i do want a boring yeah but you're
also a boring guy with the spark because
people write off sex too much i'm like
no it's really important like for a long
lasting relationship i just feel like
you can have like some people are like
well relationship the sex dies anyway so
you're gonna have to it has to be about
business and like no i'm not making sure
you take care of each other but i'm like
it's important that there's kind of if i
if like you [ __ ] me and i don't feel
like
i enjoyed it or like
i want to feel submissive to you or
something when we get into a fight it's
over for you like i will blast your ass
out of the water during a fight so like
i have to like you have to like put the
dick down
otherwise it's not gonna work that's so
true so even if we stop having sex later
but like i know like i know he could lay
down i'm like okay all right yeah all
right
okay i know you could lay that pipe so
i'll respect you i'll shut up but like
if otherwise i'm just like no bro like
i'll steamroll your house
um so yeah i'm just waiting for that's
yeah but so no yeah i want like a nice
boring guy who's
still i still have chemistry for him i
just don't want him to be like oh i want
to travel the world and like you know do
[ __ ] swim talking about him sharks
you want to move to paris but you're
like but i don't want him to want to
move
no no no she wants that she want that
paris
but like i want them to have gotten
their like what sewn their wild oats
already yeah and like just be chill um
yeah which you know and i found several
people like that too but um you deserve
to be picky you're not going to run yeah
yeah i don't know even especially
without that pressure of having that
like
biological clock that a lot of women
have yeah you're not you releasing that
yeah being like you know what not having
kids yeah it's like not on
it doesn't make you i don't want to
settle doesn't make you desperate yeah i
really don't want to it's weird like i
don't feel anything like even you have a
baby in your stomach right now and i'm
like you know whatever yeah
i have no maternal instinct
[Laughter]
no feeling like no desire so i'm like
actually it makes things a little bit
easier because i could be i could wait
another five years i guess yeah like
really get a relationship but so anyways
so i was trying to save myself
originally right i was like oh i'm
taking a [ __ ] you know i'm cleansing
my body soul mind everything i'm not
having sex anymore i don't know what one
night stands i'm gonna save it for my
boyfriend yeah and then you know i mean
at 14 and a half months went by i don't
that's special to be honest but we had
chemistry we had chemistry when i was
drunk i don't know about when i was
sober but it was a halloween night i met
him through a friend of a friend you
hadn't been drinking with all the other
guys either right no i wasn't drinking
with the other guys well no maybe like
one drink like one were you guys in
costume when you bone
okay yes we were and what were you just
as what were you dressed as so he
doesn't know what i look like because my
face was entirely logical she doesn't
know what i look like why did i imagine
when she said that it's be and i just
imagined her he doesn't see what her
face looked like because she was like in
like an inflatable dinosaur
that's the first thing and you just hear
the the
no idea what i look like because he
boned me with face makeup on
you literally have a cinderella story
what face makeup
gina just she doesn't why don't you just
say yourself she's good at makeup she
does she's
because i like to come up with some
crazy ideas in my head right now okay
you know what i wore on her halloween
episode
that's what he [ __ ] the scumbag
a skull that was starting to come back
to life because some skin was showing
through it
he literally that [ __ ] literally
[ __ ] me with a blast i thought you
knew that when you were saying boned
[Applause]
i like skeleton [ __ ] up my so my body
i work i i bought this um like skin
tight bodysuit that's like fully covered
it's black and then it has the whole
kind of your devil one but yeah yeah
it's a whole body skeleton and then i
painted my face as a skeleton so he has
no [ __ ] idea what i look like he
likes
a body suit
he knows what you're well he knows what
my body looks like but not my face it's
so funny he was still down i mean guys
are you the guys are [ __ ] ridiculous
it's a texas cinderella store oh my gosh
exactly
he's gonna go around has anyone seen my
princess with a sculpture
[Applause]
voice
does anyone see my princess or you just
never wash his face and it's like does
the makeup fit
like taking dna samples so how much does
she weigh she's all bones
[Music]
and there's like skeletons in there
he doesn't know what i look like or
anything about me but yes sex was
amazing
oh my god
one of these days you're gonna go here's
here's where i'm painting the picture
you're gonna go to a coffee shop and
you're gonna see this guy who just
walked through the door but his hat
falls off he grabs his hat right before
her door closes
and he goes bones
[Laughter]
holy [ __ ] when you guys get married your
hashtag for photos is gonna be hashtag
please make your hashtag idiot oh god
i'm getting married we haven't seen
since
i'm gonna put a casual not a casual
encounter it's a miss connections uh out
there
i met him through a friend through a
friend so i could find him but yeah i
don't think i want to now i don't know
let's just let that sit in in the time
capsule like we had the moment this is
just taking it to a great skull face
makeup and then it's over was it like
your place or him no it was at his place
i don't like strangers in my house he
knows where you live
this is all meant to be because
something about nikki's crystals and
manifestation i met a dog at my office
the other day
it's a it's his name his name was indy
oh i'm just saying here we're gonna put
a skull in that corner right before
halloween yeah right before halloween
it's meant to be
what are you saying this is meant to be
manifesting it's right below where she
sleeps when she stays here so
so yeah i afterwards i was a little i
mean i enjoyed the night it was
perfectly fine and nothing he did was
wrong but um i i regretted it a little
bit because i was like oh i was like
trying to hold on i was like i'm gonna
[ __ ] wait like a long time and i'm
gonna hold it in and i'm not gonna
[ __ ] have sex anymore you know
southern values i know but i just like
didn't want to keep i feel like i keep
giving a piece of myself away when i
have like casual relationships and i was
like i'm not going to do that anymore
i'm going to keep myself make myself
whole and not have any [ __ ] dudes
don't [ __ ]
don't [ __ ] laugh when i say hold on
i'm going to keep myself full and
completely i'm gonna keep myself 100
percent
uh for the next guy that i meet so that
i could just be you know like i don't
want any [ __ ] like guys lingering in
my like justice justice [ __ ] ruins
men's lives okay that's why we call the
temple of doom
indiana jones if you're out there right
in the top of doom
again just the holy grail of the girl
[ __ ] so i would say i was a little
disappointed that i did it even though
like i'm most like i also don't regret
it i'm in a weird place right now with
it but so you got some skeletons in your
closet oh my god
it's okay
we'll bury it thank you
this is the
yeah greatest knew i mean we knew you
were gonna have sex again eventually but
this made it like the way you did i feel
like this was the best way also like it
was almost like it wasn't me because i
had like my face painted
yeah in my backyard
but then you know i convinced myself at
the last minute when i was drunk i was
like well my next boyfriend's not saving
himself for me anyway so it's fine i
could just bone every now and then yeah
can you every time you have sex with a
guy just being to be cautious so i'll
wait and stress like a skeleton i'll
just wait every night on halloween
i'll just still have sex i'll go have
sex they call her the night rider
goddammit
this [ __ ] [ __ ]
i'm gonna kill her
my motorcycle to each one's house
story and it's gonna be great we're
starting what do you mean this is better
than two things yeah this is awesome
better than all the stores okay so now
like i feel like it's gonna be a um it's
like a milestone right so now we're
gonna refer to
uh so like so jeffrey yes before sex and
then after sex
yes you know we should mark it somehow
maybe yeah there's a headstone or
something yeah 2020 yes yes or marker
2021 2021 a s3
[Laughter]
okay the two things
there is one thing i do like about a guy
in an indiana jones costume can you guys
um in the comments just just spam
comments say congrats on the sex jokes
congrats on the winner
so speaking of bonan uh we have two
other people that born in this
relationship and now they have a baby
yeah yeah yeah this is like the only
only uh the only storyline i have is
important
very consistently very important
storyline so now i am in the fifth like
end of fifth beginning of six it's a
weird thing in the winter semester but
it's 24 weeks that i am currently not
24.5
no 24.1
because yesterday i turned 24. we love
the area we don't round here
but yeah so uh things would be going
great since i turned 21 weeks so like
three weeks ago you can drink no right
babies started kicking like crazy like
super strong kicks
and um and it's just been really fun to
like see like just feel them interact
and
i don't know but it is really strange
though because
like this pregnancy definitely does feel
a lot different it's my second kid
and i have been having like some strange
emotions about it like kind of things
that i'm kind of like working through
where i'm like oh i didn't like i don't
know it's it's just really weird to have
been a mother of one for the past 13
years and have all my love all my
attention all my everything on one kid
and then now 13 years later like such a
huge gap later like now
i have to figure out how to like share
myself with the whole another person and
it's so weird it's so weird because it's
like
the way i was trying to describe it to
casey i'm like imagine being married for
13 years with me and then all of a
sudden now you have a whole new wife
that you now have to love her and be
with her and like
do everything with her the same that you
did with me like how does your brain
compute like i don't know and then i
think if it wouldn't be so weird or so
strange or like so whatever it is that
i'm going through if it was like such a
shorter gap because it's like oh i've
had isaac for like three years like okay
cool that was like three years of me
with him and now i can actually know the
first one yet that much like it's not
like he's not like someone that you've
known forever like he's still kind of a
stranger like you know yeah exactly yeah
for three years and then just to have
like a whole nother person enter after
such a long time of me just being solely
dedicated with
isaac and
and like and just only like focusing my
love and attention and
everything with him and like now having
to like shift it and like
make like i guess i i
have like insecurities where i'm like
how do i share my love for like how's my
love gonna grow to like fit a whole
another person in it and it's just it's
really strange i don't know that's
pretty crazy that's pretty relatable
though i think for
um you know mothers that uh because i've
i'm i'm friends with a lot of teen moms
weirdly i don't and my own mom was like
young and there was a gap between me and
my brother
and uh yeah i bet there's like a i bet a
lot of people can relate to that because
it's like you want to treat each kid the
same but then it's like
is that even fair to yourself
to like have to put that pressure to
treat like okay i have to love them
exactly the same way i think you know
it's it is a lot like
dating you're like meeting someone new
you're meeting a new person that you
created
so
yeah that's hard
well you sound like you got your hands
full
anyway maybe you should make those hands
very pretty with olive in june
olive and june's an at-home nail system
they're sponsoring the show today shout
out to them their nail polishes last
seven
plus days wearing it right now longer
than seven days which is a long time for
regular now yeah that's like the wear
that like gel polishes yeah and it comes
with this whole system too where it has
a built-in base coat and um and then the
top coats really shiny they even look
like gels and there's a whole like kit
for cuticle care and it's it's really
really cool you can achieve beautiful
salon perfect nails at home without the
salon price tag and it comes with all
the tools you need in one box includes
nail clipper a nail file a nail buffer a
clean up brush polish remover pot super
glossy top coat an award-winning cuticle
serum pen a patented brush handle called
a poppy that makes it super easy to
paint with both of your hands not just
your dominant hand and it's true it
makes it super easy to paint with and
the brushes themself like in the polish
is like the perfect width of a
fingernail where you don't have to like
it's like two swipes yeah the left and
the right exactly and they have these
dry drops that dry your polish so that
you can uh touch them within 80 seconds
or less get gifts for everyone on your
list this year including you with a
special limited time offer go to
oliveinjune.com
big mood and use code big mood to save
25 on your order that's o l i v e a n d
j u n e dot com slash big mood code big
mood to save 25 on your order hurry this
offer ends november 29th olive in
june.com slash big mood code big mood
vietnamese lady nail lady approved
yes
now lydia approved the stamp of approval
of approval
and now for a quick shout out to our
sponsor nutrifoal nutrifoal supports
healthy hair growth from within by
targeting the five root causes of
thinning which are stress hormones
environment nutrition and metabolism
neutrophil is physician formulated to be
100 drug free
they use medical grade botanicals in
consistently effective dosages so you
get the most reliable results thousands
of women have taken back control of
their hair with neutrophil with many
users raving that the supplement not
only transformed their hair but restored
their confidence to why do you think my
hair is still on my head yeah you were
like losing hair i was really bad yeah
i'm really looking forward to using
their postpartum yes
neutral offers two targeted formulas for
women that are clinically shown to
improve hair growth and thickness with
less shedding through all stages of life
and you'll begin to experience results
in three to six months that's pretty
quick you can grow thicker healthier
hair and support our show by going to
nutrifoal.com and entering the promo
code big mood to save 15 off your first
month subscription this is their best
offer anywhere and it's only available
to us customers for a limited time plus
free shipping on every order get fifteen
dollars off at nutrifoal.com spelled
n-u-t-r-a-f-o-l dot com promo code big
move
neutrophil
n-u-t
i hate
y'all of nuts okay
and now you're pregnant and
no yeah so then all these insecurities
and stuff right but i'm super like since
feeling the baby kick though because
i've had all these like emotions about
the pregnancy up until that point at the
21 week mark and i really started like
i've been feeling flutters and stuff but
like starting to feel like the actual
like there's a human in there and then
also like reading every week about the
new developments and like now knowing
that they can like fully hear me
and like experience the outside world
like doing sound and stuff are you
playing music
yeah i've been like trying to play music
and stuff i'm going to sneak into your
house all night while you're sleeping i
must sleep headphones onto your belly
and i'm blasting gasolina all night
all night long the baby's gonna come out
to work and it's gonna be great or just
like me reading
things just my voice you can't read [ __ ]
i don't know no you're true you're just
true if you want them to recognize you
when they're out you should definitely
be speaking to the belly that's why like
all my friends every time everyone's
pregnant around me i'm always like
talking to the baby because i know like
they'll remember me like for example
leia when she like when she was a baby
baby like she would look at me like wait
i know your voice yeah she really nice
yeah so if you guys want to create a
bond with this kid start talking to you
know what else
um my dad was going to school when i was
in my mom's belly and he was he's an
accountant he's an accountant and he's
doing math calculations to the belly
like
well my mom was pregnant and i'm really
good at math hey there you go so it
works you want them to get ahead you
start saying school work tonight okay
we're gonna do we're gonna do all we're
gonna record all of our voices actually
no just put the podcast on yeah yeah
yeah
i'm not really there to talk to your
belly yeah well we could face the kid
comes out it's like you were a school
[ __ ]
i know her
baby doesn't recognize her until she
puts some makeup on oh [ __ ] it's just hi
auntie
that's hilarious oh my god i'm never
going to live that day
that's my new favorite just thing but
yeah so like since now like having more
of a physical connection with the baby i
guess like a lot of these insecurities
have like started like dwindling down a
bit and like now i'm like getting
more um
not as nervous and i'm looking forward
to
creating a new bond with this baby and
like i don't know it's just really
interesting to
juggle everything because even like with
isaac right now like he's
you know full-blown 13-year-old like
teenager phase and like hormonal and
stuff and like
not super
like
really
not really um showing a lot of interest
in the baby kind of like oh like if the
baby's kicking i'm like oh look isaac
let me get your hand he was just kind of
like okay whatever you can't expect too
much right no right so then i'm just
like okay so then that's how he's
dealing with the becoming but then like
he is like kind of like subconsciously
trying to get more of our attention like
whether it's positive or negative and so
it's just like dealing with him and like
his transition with
having a sibling come in
it's just been really interesting
so that's kind of it's a really big deal
like what you're going through right now
so definitely don't discount yourself
and the emotions that you're feeling
because it's a really big deal like all
of this is huge yeah yeah i think you
probably have the most important thing
going on
yeah it's it's like supposed to be easy
but also it's it's supposed to be hard
so if it feels hard i think that's okay
yeah yeah how have you been like
physically are you feeling more like
tired or is it like what's going on
there ever since i've been in the second
trimester i have regained a lot of my
energy i don't have that nausea anymore
but but now like at this specific point
in time i have had i do feel my body
different and really different in a
sense where now i have a lot of lower
back pain like here and there
so i've been having to like do a lot of
yoga stretches and that really helps me
a lot um i've also like my boobs got
huge like i've cheated
i needed survive
i needed to buy you know those bra
extenders like literally a little like
extender from i have it on now because
i'm like whoa like this is why don't you
just go braless would it hurt oh no
they're too big yeah like they're too
big to be slapping everywhere yeah
i need support yeah so get those udders
babe yeah you know dude it's crazy and
then like when now when i shower and i
see like my belly popping out more yeah
i'm like oh my gosh
when's the last time you've seen your
panocha i could still see it
i can still see it for now but it is
getting harder like if i'm shaving or
whatever because we got to cut a little
further down oh that's another thing
like now i'm hairier oh like the
hormones yeah yeah like i've been like
shaving my belly because i'm like it's
like
it's kind of like a peach or a happy
trail bailey happy drinking
yeah like so you know how like i always
laser you have a mustache over your
belly button
[Music]
what does it feel like i feel strong boy
vibes yeah like strong boy
vibes but a lot of the symptoms like a
lot of the things like for example like
if i'm gonna crave either savory or
salty i mean sweet or savory i'm craving
more sweets and they say like that's
more of a girl
um and then like how i'm carrying maybe
he's just
yeah and like even like how low i'm
carrying a parent like some people say
carrying low is a boy and other people
think carrying love was a girl i heard
like the basketball shape is boy and
then like get if your body gets whiter
than it's a girl do you think you're
whiter or like personally i think i'm
more of a basketball but then other
people see me like casey or like
i don't know other people will just be
like oh you look white like you look
like you're having a girl so i'm like i
don't know i can't tell because you've
always just been so small yeah you're
just small in general yeah yeah i think
within this next month right that's when
it's like you blow up because that's
another thing too because you're asking
about like physically
um i feel myself like out of breath a
lot now um and my stomach like around my
like especially around my rib area after
i eat a big meal i really feel it like
stretching like i feel like like do you
remember when i felt like i got fat over
the pandemic same my skin was like felt
like it was stretching yeah or like
those growing pains that you get when
you're when you're a kid like no i don't
remember that i i don't know i kind of
feel that like in my stomach so i'm like
whoa like it's like really like
stretching so i've been really good
about putting on like the uh i use um
cocoa butter no i use uh bio oil so i
took bio oil everywhere and i'm like
okay cool no stretch bags not stretch
marks yet what's up
what do the grafts say
how big is the baby right now right now
it's a cantaloupe size
that's big yeah
cantaloupe or what was the other
pomegranates are pomegranate smaller oh
that's weird yeah they have different
apps they say different things
either someone's eating small
cantaloupes yeah or very huge popular
toxins yeah
it's it's so annoying that they go based
off of fruits yeah why can't you go
based off of like common like households
americans will measure with anything but
the [ __ ] matrix i'm going to say a
softball
yeah a softball that's not a country
it's pretty big
pomegranate is a softball size yeah who
knows fun fact in australia cantaloupes
are called rock melons because those
people are weird as [ __ ] well that makes
more sense than cantaloupe it doesn't
make any smaller named it dude like
what's this
rockman like
orange really orange that's true
yeah
maybe raiders fan by the time i move
on
a little more
yeah
and then um yeah so i've been going to
chiropractor too to help me with the
body changes so you're due in february
late february february oh we might have
a valentine baby or like later yeah
president maybe i'm hoping late february
so i'll be pisces and join the water
club yeah yeah oh not early aquarius
yeah
eight air signs we don't have air signs
in this podcast
[Music]
yeah only yeah
isaac was born a week early so
who knows maybe a week or two weeks
earlier yeah they're kicking right now
hi baby oh another thing i've been
getting uh braxton hicks contractions
now which is like a contraction but it's
not painful and like i'm literally
having one right now where it like it's
it makes my whole uterus hard
so like it's prepping for labor wait why
would your uterus be hard for labor it's
turned on so
it contracts to like help the like
squeeze the baby out
so right now it's like practice
practicing it's practicing it's
literally positioning
it's rehearsing it's rehearsing for
birth yeah cute it's like when it needs
that much of a rehearsal yeah like when
ai is a marathon when you give birth
it's like when my printer i put new ink
in and it pretends to print it's like
yeah this out
okay yeah i think i could print colors
we're printing out a baby right now yeah
for sure so yeah it went away now so
like feel i'll show i'll tell you next
time but like see how soft it is uh-huh
uh i'll have you feel the next time and
it's like hard it's really weird that's
creepy but it doesn't hurt it's just a
little bit
uncomfortable i don't like being
uncomfortable i think that's why i'd be
a terrible
like pregnant person yeah like i want it
for the experience experience and to
like wear flowy dresses in a photo like
have like a cool photo shoot you could
just put it like
comfort
put a fake bump on and take your bra no
it has to be authentic
nope
i need a
inauthentically authentic photo
nothing about pregnancy is selling it
right now
yeah and then afterwards that's like
you're relieved of the pregnancy but
then now you got a kid for 18 years
not just that but your body is never
your body's all the same anymore it's a
new body
you end up like being granted with a new
body it's a new body
and then that's definitely how i'm
feeling now where i'm like whoa like i'm
not used to having this much mass on my
body so i'm like this is an adjustment
oh what you're going to do with all that
mass
oh that mask inside your thumb
yeah it's been fun like shopping for the
baby too
i don't know and you don't know the name
have you guys thought of any names yet
because yeah
they'd have like uh oh if it's a girl
named boy
how do you feel about gino and gina
i'm just saying yeah
uh jessica and jessie we've been
thinking about nicholas oh yeah there
you go
that's cute there's a boy named for tiff
timothy timothy
yeah who knows
what is it tiffany tiffo no we don't we
don't like that that's my alter ego
the like mean one yeah the mean one the
one that's mean to me that's tiffo but
yeah i mean we thought of names here and
there but nothing really
anything like do you know like kind of
what ethnic type of vibe you're going
for not really like chinese american
mexican random not really
okay
she's allowed to say it okay she's
allowed to say that okay
chinese in her body yeah
oh you know what's crazy too that i've
been feeling um is like
cravings for chinese food i literally
just like this morning
indoctrinated yeah
like this morning
i haven't been craving pizza fries but i
have been craving so this morning i just
told casey about a dream i had last
night where i was eating like dim sum
and like i had a whole shopping cart
full of din some food
so i feel like i've been having those
dreams because i live in austin now and
there's no good at like asian food so
i'm like i want korean barbecue
with the japanese food all they have is
sushi
we should eat yeah we should eat girl um
i guess by the time this episode comes
out i'm already on tv yeah
when is the first episode coming out uh
november 16th is when we launched
g4 2014.
better watch this [ __ ] show everybody
so this is pre-recorded obviously i'm
not on tv yet as of now but then by the
time this episode comes out i will be on
tv uh so it's on an actual network on tv
tv yeah we're on the old on the tvs that
we used to watch
because we're under comcast and we're on
a bunch of different things and actual
like cable tv
and it's been weird man it's been crazy
like we're we're preparing to launch
right now is the what the we are
10 days 10 days away from launch
and it's been non-stop at the office man
we've been filming we've been doing pr
interviews and stuff and it's so cool
are you excited i'm scared
because yeah that's a for the reaction
it's related to excitement uh we had
like an all hands meeting and they're
like we're projected to launch with into
like 150 million households first
and then double that by next year yeah
so it's it's it's been crazy it's been
weird like i i haven't fully
like digested it yet yeah yeah until i
guess i see it on tv yeah
um and i i don't know like this is it's
crazy that this has all happened because
like i said this was the dream tv
network on one yeah as a kid and here i
am
uh and i'm living up to your
expectations yeah yeah you can manifest
your dreams people oh yeah so we uh we
moved into our 67 square foot studio
that we built 67 thousand six
yeah that's it
uh
and it's cool like the office looks
[ __ ] awesome like a gamer office can
we visit you yeah yeah and then um we
have like multiple studios we're going
to be streaming our on our channel 24 7
but also be on tv and
i'm losing so much yeah i'm learning so
much about tv
and it's just i'm a little bit scared
you know like this is a bigger audience
than i've ever had before uh i'm having
that whole imposter syndrome thing
you're worried that's natural
but just know you're qualified you're
beyond qualified everything girl yeah
thank you yeah so we're freaking out so
i like to think that we help by like you
practicing oh yeah you know here like so
kind of cool like so don't forget us
don't forget this little piece really
helped you
i'm like if i don't throw up on my first
days filming yeah sure i guess
but i'm scared and and also this past
month has been crazy because
um
it's just been a [ __ ] really good i'm
so glad to see you guys today because
it's been a [ __ ] roller coaster yeah
my grandmother had a stroke oh no and
she was paralyzed on the left side and
it's [ __ ] terrifying oh [ __ ] do they
know why or what happened she's old man
yeah and then but she's regaining her
money that's good she
is she can feed herself again so it's
good so we don't know what the extent of
the damage just yet but it's going
better yeah so that's cool that's
awesome and they're doing like physical
therapy and everything mm-hmm that's
good um because the first time we
checked in on her she did not pass the
swallow test we had to put a feeding
tube in her if that's a permanent thing
that would've been [ __ ] awful
but she's she passed a swallow test
she's moving a little bit on her left
side she's ready to go home thankfully
so that's good um and then also one
morning i woke up and i had a [ __ ]
crazy severe infection in my wisdom
tooth oh yes
uh you're going through a lot of stress
too yeah your body is like defenses are
so much i'm stressed out listening to
you right
maya so my wisdom tooth was growing
halfway out of the gum and there's a
flop of gum still half covering the
tooth so there's like food stuck inside
of it and i got this crazy infection
my face was swollen
and so i went to the my my dentist was
out of town so i went to a local dentist
i was like yo i need you to tell me
what's going on because if it's an
abscess it'll go into my bloodstream and
i'll die yeah um but it was just a gum
infection and then he's like we can
flush it out for you but you need to go
to an oral surgeon and get your wisdom
teeth taken out i'm like okay i guess
and then so i had to rush to so i rushed
a doctor they dude this was like the
worst thing ever so they um numbed me
out and i've told this story before but
lidocaine doesn't work well with my body
i mean
yeah yeah so i need extra lidocaine
otherwise i can feel everything you
should ask for the kind that doesn't
have the adrenaline in it because i feel
like for us like we have the i think we
both probably have the same gene where
like the lidocaine with the adrenaline
it doesn't really work so i asked for
the lidocaine without it or something or
whatever it is you can get it without
the adrenaline in it yeah and then i
think it works better for people like us
maybe oh okay oh i didn't know that was
it just knows a lot about
pharmaceuticals
but she's an accountant right she's an
accountant
so i go in and they're like
they give me all this lidocaine extra
lidocaine and they flush it out and they
have to aggressively scrape everything
out but when he scraped my he got
caught in one of my tooths
and yanked my whole face
and i swear to god you also got skull
[ __ ] up
yeah true that's true she accepted it
she said also
[Applause]
also me and you one on the scene
skull [ __ ] same month and then so
indiana jones
so he yanked my whole mouth and
all the lidocaine disappeared i feel
like yeah it went full on pain
and so they like
i like i'm sitting i'm sitting there
about to pay for my process or whatever
and they send me this prescription to go
to a pharmacist i go to the pharmacy
which is literally across the street
from the dentist and i'm like literally
about to pass out in pain i can handle
pain well like i've been through
surgeries i've been i'm fine just the
way you normally have sex is very good
yeah
oh you think i would enjoy this but this
is bad dude like i told the pharmacy
like i need you guys to hurry because
i'm about to pass out they gave me
tylenol with codeine and once they gave
it to me it was only a 10-minute wait
but it was the longest way to my life
yeah i was hyperventilating trying to
just keep it together there was a karen
in line i wanted to [ __ ] her out
because she was being a [ __ ] but i
couldn't open my mouth so
once they gave me the medication i
rented a target bathroom i took it with
target sink water so i probably have all
kinds of diseases now yeah you know
whatever
yeah right at least yeah exactly and
then i took i took the medication i
realized my doctor told me do not take
this and uh operate machinery because
there's coding in it i was like [ __ ] and
i was i literally i literally lived two
minutes away from that target so i got
into my car i rushed home because i
didn't want it to kick in yeah
came home and like two minutes later
kicks in and passed out oh my god so
they took out
and then so i had to make a appointment
with an oral surgeon and i go and he
looks at me he's like oh well that's not
good because i'm swollen and then so
he's like we need to take out your
wisdom teeth we can do it now if you
want you got anything else to do i'm
like i guess you know because they told
me someone go with you yes okay because
i already scolded you for not calling
for that first one no
everything just happened so guys
well the thing is it's because they told
me i'm like young lady better call me
next time i know she's already started
because they told me it was we're gonna
see you and if it's bad we do surgery if
not then we let you go so i prepped the
night before just in case for surgery i
didn't eat just in case i have to get
put under i called my girlfriend to
drive me drove in they were like okay
yeah we can do it now i'm like okay cool
i have everything prepared i also
learned on tik tok that if you chug a
[ __ ] ton of pineapple juice the night
before you don't swell so the night
before i'm like chugging pineapple juice
i go in there like yeah we're gonna do
today i'm like cool they yanked out all
four and i told them i want to be put
under completely just knock me out and
he's like yeah sure we can do that uh
knock me out i didn't realize the
process was only 30 minutes i thought it
was going to be longer
so they took it out it didn't take long
to cut the tooth off apparently right i
didn't know um and of course i told him
i want to keep all my teeth and they let
me i can't believe you keep them i'm so
mad i tried to keep my teeth and they
wouldn't let me have them imagine that's
going to be your christmas presents my
tuna
necklace yeah the wisdom teeth and they
were coming out in little chunks because
they like yeah mine was mine was like
they were really impacted with my jaw so
yeah it was just like sharks well the
top two they pulled just yanked them out
but the bottom two were impacted yeah
yeah i only just wanted to keep the top
ones i wanted to make them gold and like
exactly
the necklace
um so they yanked out all four and
let me keep all of them i went home i
didn't swell at all the pineapple thing
works dude
and then recovery was easy well i'm glad
the pineapple juice works for that uh
old website it didn't work from others
it doesn't work for other things
and then it was fun because like i
remember
so i came home
knocked out for three hours everything
was super easy i woke up i was big
chilling with like gauze in my face i
didn't swell and i remembered i had like
this teeth cleaning scraping kit that i
got from amazon so after i woke up i sat
in my living room and started scraping
up my wisdom teeth just cleaning it up
and cleaning all the way if you did that
before then you wouldn't have gotten
infected
true
called out
wait you should use a magic eraser on it
oh
yeah i should so i'm like scraping all
this tissue off my tooth right and it's
all bloody i'm like cleaning it all up
my sister comes out she's in town
visiting she's like what are you doing
like
clear my teeth
scrubbing it and just scraping it like
i'm trying to figure out what to do with
it now because i just got four teeth and
now i'm wisdom toothless and on tv
that's like pkdhd
yeah right
so now i have like tooth holes in my
mouth i'm still healing yeah but it's a
lot better you gotta not drink with a
straw oh yeah i remember that you can't
suck on things yeah sorry yeah
throwing up
yeah
throw up you can't control that i know
well like they gave me vicodin when i
got mine and they were like don't throw
up and don't do this and i like vomited
everywhere with viking i can't take it
my doctors were so concerned they gave
me like every pain medicine under the
sun because i need extra so they gave me
like tylenol tylenol codeine i tell you
overdoses
yeah that's scary yeah because i can
always just still feel but i'm okay now
and i'm glad i got them out
and that whole chapter is over yeah
anyways i'm auctioning off my teeth on
ebay gamer girl teeth right gamer girl
teeth gamer girl molar
keep your boobs
you've had so many things come out of
you
i can make a living off of selling so
many things instead of just taking out
of my body but yeah so there's that in
just tv and day jobs and i
have been learning everything about
office life we're growing up we're
growing up you know i have my own desk
and monitor and [ __ ] it's [ __ ] crazy
right
but life is changing and you know and
we're very thankful very thankful thank
you for this so i hope you're thinking
things that you're thankful for and
we're like you don't have to make the
thanksgiving thing i'm trying to make it
work
we're thankful that you guys weren't
thanksgiving colors did you notice us
yeah we tried to do a thanksgiving
outfit at least see thanks i'm actually
going to wear this on thanksgiving wait
a minute let's go around real quick what
do you think leave it in the comments
yeah well obviously i'm thankful for
this baby because i'm thankful for my
family i'm thankful for you guys but she
said one thing
what can you one thing that is one thing
you can say multiple things that is one
thing yeah all the important people in
my life is what i'm thinking i'm
thankful that just got burned
why
because i want my friends to be happy
yeah i feel like your meter was low you
know so like i was happy for like a day
but i'm back to normal now
well i'm thankful for all the future
bonings
that just will encounter
um i'm thankful for my new job i'm
actually enjoying it yay
i am also thankful that uh just got
school booned
and i'm thankful for all the crazy life
changes that's going on in our lives
it's positive and having you guys around
still during this crazy
shitstorm that's been going on and yeah
it's like a grounding for us even though
the traveling pants are traveling
everywhere
you can keep track of those pants but
yeah the pants are everywhere and we're
thankful for you guys yeah for casey
doing our [ __ ] and you guys watching us
put into the chat actually not the chat
i'm sorry i'm in stream mode put in the
comments what you guys are thankful for
and i'm thankful for our instagram at
big mood girls i'm thankful that we have
merch that you guys can check out
and i'm thankful for our sponsors i'm
thankful for kittens and coffee we have
stuff launching oh my god black friday
go ahead i'm thankful for [ __ ] they
don't tell you the podcast
we're thankful for we're thankful for
check out g14
tv
all right okay well i know how to uh and
i'm thankful for tiffany's channel
we love you thank you for taxes
because she says i do taxes
she does what accountants do all right
we love you thanks for watching give us
a thumbs up like our channel give us
five stars thank you for this ending
next
week visit our sponsors we love you
i'm thankful for